[Música]
es un genio que dejó huella para siempre
en francia
se trata de boba
el arquitecto militar de louis 14
quien imaginó un cinturón de hierro para
proteger el país
un centenar de ciudadelas las zonas más
impresionantes que las otras una
herencia tan majestuosa como difícil de
llevar en especial para habrían son
donde el maestro se superó para proteger
dicha ciudad enclavada particularmente
expuesta
nos encontramos en el corazón de la
construcción al interior del palacio de
justicia de la ciudad los visitantes
pueden apreciar el trabajo del
arquitecto
vemos las fortificaciones de boban
omni rodean la ciudad con la parte alta
que tiene la forma de estas
fortificaciones en estrella y para
proteger la ciudad empotrada juegan
ubicó seis fuertes en las alturas
el fuerte de las cabezas es el fuerte
más grande de todos los esta barrera del
siglo 18 el fuerte de las tres cabezas
plaza central del sistema de defensa se
encuentra a
1.450 metros de altura este hombre es el
guarda de las llaves
desde aquí se puede ver la ciudad
entonces se puede vigilar al atacante
estando protegido por los fuertes de los
alrededores de esta ley la salette aquí
podrá disparar hacia el fuerte de las
tres cabezas que lo defienden tal como
el castillo cubre el fuerte que cubre la
ciudad estas construcciones están
inhabitadas desde hace varios años en
2009 cuando el ejército salió de briand
son la ciudad fortificada quedó
abandonada la partida del ejército de
brians son no fue sencilla porque la
ciudad quedó sin guarnición durante más
de 300 años entre mil 692 y 2009 desde
bomba no existe la tradición militar en
brians son según la cual aquí se nace se
vive y se muere al ritmo del clarín esta
joya del patrimonio está abandonada pero
400 kilómetros más al norte la ciudadela
de besançon permanece llena aquí boban
construyó uno de los lugares más fuertes
de europa sobre un espolón rocoso que
sobresale sobre la ciudad desde 2008
este monumento hace parte del patrimonio
mundial de la unesco scott cada año
acoge a no menos de 250 mil personas
llegué con un ahijado de cinco años le
explicaba mira un poco ves estas
construcciones en forma de arco son
cosas construidas hace 400 años es
increíble
el monumento las piedras en las piedras
viejas cuanto más viejo más las aprecian
ya pues inicia la historia de la
ciudadela se confunden con la de su
creador
encarnado por este actor durante una
visita
[Música]
hola jóvenes se basa en la pedestre
marqués de bojan comisario encargado de
las fortificaciones del rey todo lo que
ven aquí en besançon esta ciudadela es
mi obra
cuban podría estar orgulloso porque su
ciudadela construida a finales del siglo
17 es un edificio excepcional el
objetivo era hacer de besançon el
bastión este del reino
entonces boban concibió una fortaleza
cuya construcción duró treinta años
fortifica la ciudad de besançon en tres
niveles sobre el fuerte grifo y luego la
muralla fortificada alrededor del doble
y la ciudadela que asegura el lugar
murallas de 20 metros de alto y 5 de
ancho y por todas partes garitas y
atalayas para ver llegar el enemigo en
el siglo 17 esta ciudadela era
inexpugnable porque boban lo había
previsto todo salvo tal vez la usura del
tiempo la ciudadela es una obra
financiada en parte gracias a visitantes
cada vez más numerosos
teniendo en cuenta las intemperies que
ha habido desde hace 300 años la piedra
está congelada está en este estado
entonces quitamos toda la piedra la
funda y el envoltorio y conservamos toda
la parte interna que está sana
en esta sola torre hay 40 metros cúbicos
de piedra por cambiar
las nuevas piedras de la ciudadela
provienen de estos enormes bloques de
piedra caliza extraídos de esta cantera
de piedra calcárea muy dura cercana al
granito que hay que ser luchar antes de
tallas en esta obra de la ciudadela
entre 5 y 10 talladores trabajan de
manera permanente
reconstituyen de manera idéntica las
piezas retiradas de los muros de la
fortaleza cuánto tiempo se demoran en
cada piedra esta está finamente
trabajada hay que dedicarle casi una
jornada de trabajo puesto al año
he aquí un muro que fue reconstruido de
manera idéntica casi el 80% de la piedra
es nuevo
todas las piedras antiguas fueron
ubicadas en su lugar exacto y todas las
piedras fueron moldeadas iguales
durarán 300 años
[Música]
actualmente las obras de bo van ya no
tienen vocación militar pero siguen
siendo testigos del ingenio de uno de
los más grandes arquitectos de nuestra
historia
[Música]